je ne suis pas un candidat doux rêveur
j'ai 45 ans travaille agronomique sur le
terrain où 45 ans de travail
d'enseignement surtout à l'institut
national agronomique de paris donc dire
que je suis un candidat pas sérieux
c'est tout de même s'avancer un peu vite
quand on va étudier les problèmes au
village avec les paysans avec les
agriculteurs
on doit être sérieux par ailleurs si je
ne vais pas sérieux est-ce que j'aurais
été choisi par plus de 50 associations
représentant plus de cent mille
adhérents répartis à travers la france
est-ce que s'il ne veut pas sérieux joe
non j'aurais été présentée par 176
signature sans compter celles qui sont
arrivés en retard dans 80 plus de 80
maires de communes rurales de petites
communes qui sont tous les jours en
contact avec le problème de la terre
dont 65 agriculteurs dont 15 médecins
des notaires des commerçants et autres
notabilités je représente ici un
programme écologique un mouvement
écologique est d'abord ce mot nouveau
pour beaucoup d'entre vous l'écologie
qu'est ce que c'est ce n'est pas un mot
gadget qui a été inventé pour les
besoins de cette campagne c'est un mot
créé en 1866 par le biologiste allemand
ernst haeckel qui étudie les rapports
entre les êtres vivants et les milieux
où ils vivent aujourd'hui je viens
revenir en france pour étudier avec vous
les problèmes très graves qui se pose
après avoir beaucoup étudier les
problèmes de la faim dans le monde
dans le tiers monde j'estime que
aujourd'hui il est temps de s'occuper
des problèmes de nos pays mais nous les
écologistes
on nous accuse d'être des prophètes de
malheur et d' annoncer l'apocalypse
comme l'apocalypse nous l'annonçons pas
elle est là parmi nous elle se trouve
dans les nuages de pollution qui nous
domine dans les eaux d'égout qui sont
que sont devenus nos rives
r nos estuaires et nolito romarin on
espérait tirer de ces eaux de la mer des
ressources importantes
on pensait que ce sera le grenier de
l'humanité de demain
coc estuaire ses plateaux continentaux
se sont aujourd'hui nos poubelles
là où on jette tous nos détritus
on habite j'étais un vieux professeur
qui se baladait à vélo mais oui le 16
mars j'étais avec mes amis de la terre
de la porte d'orléans à la concorde pour
montrer que paris pourrait être rejoint
pour un jour et dans quelques rues le
domaine de ces instruments de transport
à deux groupes qui ne pollue pas on a
dit que j'étais donc un fantaisiste
je crois que les vingt livres que j'ai
écrits la diffusion qu'ils ont eue haute
beaucoup de poids à de tels arguments
je me présente ici comme un candidat
propre à tous les sens du terme puisque
nous sommes pour la propreté de l'air et
de l'eau et parce que tous les comptes
des élections seront présentés au public
seront officielles les un conte l'heure
le coût de leur campagne en millions de
francs lourd
nous allons les compter avec un tout
petit nombre de millions de phoques
léger candidat propre qui respecte les
murs qui sait que le papier est rare
comme l'énergie et qui par conséquent ne
va pas couvrir nos murs des affiches et
vous ne verrez pas ma tête sur les murs
de nos villes
d'abord lorsque nous n'avons pas
d'argent ensuite parce que je n'ai pas
envie de voir ma tête sur tous les murs
de la ville à quoi ça sert quels
arguments ça apporte de montrer sa
biquette sur tous les murs de la ville
c'est une grosse une grossière plaisante
un candidat pauvres que je voulais dire
c'est pour cela que nous sommes
amarré au port de l'alma à côté du pont
de l'alma sur un bateau-mouche étaient
gracieusement mis à notre disposition
par un ami de l'environnement qui
s'inquiète notamment de voir notre dame
assailli par les
au tour à cause d'un projet de voie
express rive gauche
nous serons les seuls à parler d d'un
projet global d'avenir
les seuls à regarder en face les menaces
de notre expansion illimitée le pillage
du tiers-monde amène un gaspillage
inouïe de nos matières premières la
france consomme et 5 millions de tonnes
de pétrole
en 1939 la france consomme et 120
millions de tonnes de pétrole
en 1973 une telle expansion illimité ne
peut pas se poursuivre ceux qui vous
disent le contraire sont des
inconscients ou des menteurs nous
n'aurons plus les moyens d'acheter des
telles quantités notre économie que l'on
dit de plus en plus indépendante depuis
trente ans notre est depuis quinze ans
surtout notre économie depuis quinze ans
est de plus en plus dépendantes
la france a perdu son indépendance
économique puisque toute son économie
dépend d'une forme d'énergie importés
qui va devenir de plus en plus coûteuses
ces matières premières que l'étirement
nous fournissait presque gratuitement
c'était le pillage du tiers-monde
pillage de matières premières sous payés
ce qui nous permettait de gaspiller ces
matières premières d'une façon
inconsidérée
alors il va falloir cesser ces problèmes
de pillage cesser ses formes de
gaspillage qui aboutissent à des choses
un près semblable aux états unis sont
rejetées chaque année 48 heures de
boîtes de conserve vides 65 milliards
d'emballages en métal et en plastique et
il y en avant en 1965 le coût
d'enlèvement de tous ces détritus se
lever à 15 milliards de francs louvre
notre population ne peut augmenter
indéfiniment et vous savez ce qui va se
passer
eh bien nous allons bientôt manquer de
l'eau et c'est pourquoi je bois devant
vous un verre d'eau précieuse puisque
avant la fin du siècle si nous
continuons intel
or demain elle manquera à lundi je vous
dis au revoir et j'espère vous revoir
pour vous expliquer notre projet global
d'avenir merci les amis
[Musique]